[Música]
dejamos el espacio para venir a la
tierra seguimos en directo américa con
economía daniela blandón hoy martes ayer
lunes apagón total en las redes sociales
como lo vivió pues raúl tengo que
confesar que me dolió al principio pero
ya después como que lo interioricé y me
gustó lo fuimos superando y a mí si bien
sabes yo me sentía tranquilo libre pero
bueno solo un día así ya ya hoy era
mucha ansiedad
daniela qué pasó ayer en temer en
términos económicos pues mire el apagón
mundial que duró alrededor de seis horas
y de redes vinculadas a facebook
específicamente tuvo sus efectos y
provocó todo un temblor en wall street
al cierre de la jornada cuando ya todo
volvió a la normalidad el propio mark
zuckerberg air publicó en su cuenta
personal que facebook instagram whatsapp
messenger estaban de nuevo en línea y
hasta pidió perdón por la interrupción
pero eso raúl no impidió que hubiera una
venta masiva que hizo que las acciones
de facebook cayeran casi un 5 por ciento
el lunes
lo que también arrastró a otras
tecnológicas que nada tuvieron que ver
con el apagón como twitter que perdió
casi un 6% y hasta microsoft y apple que
también perdieron más del 2% hablemos
del dinero como soy yo eso reflejado en
términos de la plata raúl pues la
capitalización bursátil sólo de esta
empresa de facebook cayó en un día cerca
de 40 mil millones de dólares que
haríamos nosotros con 40 mil millones de
julio de vido pero si nos vamos al
patrimonio personal de mark zuckerberg
este se redujo en casi seis mil millones
de dólares según la agencia bloomberg y
eso le costó un escalón en el ranking de
las personas más ricas del mundo
su fortuna ahora es de 117 mil millones
de dólares lo que lo relega al sexto
puesto por debajo de bill gates daniela
cambiamos ahora de información nos vamos
a nuestro continente precisamente aquí a
colombia y también venezuela porque
estos dos países reabrieron su paso
fronterizo más venezuela que colombia
retiró por supuesto ya finalmente los
containers que pusieron en 2019 para
evitar radio humanitaria en términos de
comercio qué significa
pues raúl mire la relación comercial de
ambos países ha sido de altibajos
históricamente eso no es un secreto pero
después digamos del reciente conflicto
binacional en agosto de 2015 las
consecuencias se hicieron muy evidentes
en las cifras ahora las vamos a repasar
el intercambio comercial ese año cayó un
44 por ciento como vemos acá total pero
si nos vamos de venezuela a colombia
cayó un 34 por ciento en ese 2015 de
colombia a venezuela un 47 por ciento
hasta poco más de mil 60 millones de
dólares pues lo que hay que decir según
esto es que según un informe de la época
de la cámara de integración económica es
que hubo bastantes consecuencias
económicas en ese entonces por ejemplo
lo que más exportaba colombia eran
combustibles productos farmacéuticos y
confitería y venezuela le surtida de
productos químicos abonos y combustibles
también daniela pues ojalá que este
comercio se regulariza y se benefician
las familias que viven de este comercio
el comercio fronterizo vamos ahora a
hollywood porque hay un sector que se
podría ir a huelga que el sector estamos
hablando pues no estamos hablando
precisamente de los actores nos vemos en
pantalla al aula estamos hablando del
equipo de producción maquilladores
operadores de cámara operadores de
sonido que sabemos que son bastante
importantes
pues viven los miembros de la alianza
internacional de empleados de escenarios
teatrales que representa a unos 60 miles
de ellos dijeron que el 90 y el 90 por
ciento de ellos votó rotundamente para
autorizar una huelga si no pueden llegar
a un acuerdo con sus empleadores para
que les mejoren las condiciones por
ejemplo raúl reducir las horas de
trabajo que han aumentado a medida que
sube la demanda de programas de
televisión y de películas
particularmente en plataformas como
netflix disney + apple tv o amazon vídeo
escuchemos
el problema es ya sabes las producciones
pueden durar 14 horas al día tal vez más
16 horas y esto ha sido así desde
siempre décadas y décadas así es la
producción pero parece que la pandemia
ha hecho que la gente se detenga y
piense realmente ya no queremos vivir
así no veo qué bueno weiwei amor
pues raúl la última gran huelga en
hollywood fue de guionistas de cine y
televisión a finales de 2007 duró tres
meses y obligó a las cadenas de
televisión a repetir comedias y dramas
este martes parece que se van a reunir
de nuevo pues para tratar de buscar
solución y ojalá lo solucionen daniela e
indicadores bueno después de un día
bastante difícil en wall street raúl
asia cerró mixta la bolsa de tokio cayó
más del 2% por temor a que suban los
impuestos corporativos como lo propuso
el primer ministro nuevo en europa las
bolsas operan al alza impulsadas por las
acciones bancarias que están también al
alza el día de hoy para finalizar que
nos trae como cifra del día sabía usted
que hoy se cumplen 10 años de la muerte
de steve jobs no sabía bueno él es el
fundador de apple todos lo sabemos
también y pues las cifras son los 2,3
billones de dólares que vale hoy esta
empresa en la bolsa de nueva york lo que
la hace la más valiosa del mundo haga
sus cuentas estos dos veces el pib de
méxico en un año o 55 veces el pib de
bolivia increíble genio daniela este
personaje que ya no nos acompañamos en
este mundo muchísimas gracias nos vemos
con más economía directo américa vamos
ahora con nuestro reportaje le parece
vamos a grados